do you know what makes a real hero it's  not the costumes the gadgets the cool  powers it's having your own movie and  that has always been my dream what are  you doing just giving the people what  the wall it's not about Wonder Woman  it's about us the Teen Titan no one  wants to see us fool Wonder Woman  inspires people and we do not yes Wonder  Woman is great but I love Wonder Woman  narrator guy just do your thing for the  creators of Teen Titans go  it's about the courage it's about action  it's the superhero movie to end all  superhero movies  [Music]  hopefully wasn't a fart that was just  air leaving my butt which is a fart Teen  Titans goes to the movies because if  Aquaman can get a movie anyone can  [Music]  you